hundreds of thousands of people are
waking up without power as a deadly
storm system barrels across the
Northeast heavy winds toppled trees onto
homes and cars in Pennsylvania overnight
the storm brought hail flash flooding
and possible tornadoes to the state the
same system hit parts of the south over
the weekend at least 10 tornadoes
slammed Mississippi more than a hundred
homes were damaged or destroyed severe
weather is blamed for at least eight
deaths including three in Texas Maria
very al is in hard-hit Alto Texas south
of Dallas Maria good morning good
morning everywhere you look in this town
there is complete and utter destruction
here you can tell trees have been
uprooted there was a home behind me it
is now completely gone and there is
debris scattered everywhere the National
Weather Service does confirm a powerful
EF three tornado ripped right through
this tab with winds powerful enough
coming through here at 140 miles an hour
picked up some cars through them clear
across a field they are now in a pile
right behind me from the air you can see
how widespread the destruction is across
southeastern Texas it happened so quick
I didn't have time to get scared until
it was over
a powerful twister cut through Franklin
Texas Saturday destroyed more than 50
homes in just minutes police say at
least half of Altos 1,200 residents are
dealing with some type of damage from
the storm 200 are displaced we was in
the closet we heard a roar like a train
and next time to win we will lift it a
little bit and we started rocking and we
moved over and we started praying how
many people
Cecil Morgan and its family huddled in
this corner of their home while powerful
winds peeled away the walls and roof we
befriended we made it out as I we follow
the youngest victims of this storm are
two brothers three-year-old Jace creel
an 8-year old Dylan were killed in
Angelina County when a tree crushed
their car back in nearby Alto another
person was killed and around two dozen
were injured at the Catamounts State
Historic Site when a tornado ripped
apart the building during a Native
American cultural event it was really
rough you know just trying to keep
everybody calm and safe and we're really
great community and the Caddo Indians
are fabulous people jail Skinner has
lived next to the Caddo sight for nearly
35 years the four homes on his property
were all destroyed
will you rebuild oh yeah stick around
yeah you know as of right now the Altos
School District has canceled classes
until they can make sure that the
buildings are safe at the height of this
storm more than a hundred thousand
people were without power across the
country right now as we drove up we saw
crews feverishly trying to work to get
things back on track because more
weather is expected in this area on
Wednesday Nora mmm tough storms there
Maria thank you